we have witnessed not one but two
monumental battles in the final season
of Game of Thrones the King's Landing
episode was polarizing to say the least
just as the Winterfell battle was two
episodes before it but one of these
clashes was an emotional rollercoaster
with an intensely satisfying conclusion
while the other just felt anticlimactic
the show may have made some questionable
lighting decisions in the long night but
director Miguel Zapotec managed to hold
our white-knuckled attention throughout
the hour plus battle by giving us
essentially four movies in one here's
why the Battle of Winterfell outshine
the Battle of King's Landing and in fact
why it will go down is one of the best
battles in TV history be warned
spoilers are coming like the long night
the bells was directed by Miguel sipoc
neck the mastermind behind seminal
battle episodes like hardhome and battle
of the bastards but this most recent
entry felt more like a massacre than a
battle the show spent seasons building
up to this attack yet all it takes is a
few jerk Horace's to take the Westerosi
capital after that the episode devolves
into a spectacle of mass slaughter with
most of the victims nameless when it
comes to extended war sequences monotony
is really the enemy in contrast in the
Winterfell episodes a posh Nick wisely
staved off monotony by dividing the
fight into four different acts each
fitting into a different cinematic genre
phase changes were key to avoid battle
fatigue looking at the time the
character spent on-screen over the
duration of the episode you can see how
act 1 is mostly comprised of short
jittery snippets to get us on edge that
suspense turns into a protracted horror
show with arias stealth scene in act 2
filmed and extended takes with a few
memorable jump scares this is followed
by slightly more quick cutting action in
act 3 and finally a slow-motion drama in
act 4
in the Battle of King's Landing arguably
the tensest moment is when silence falls
on the capital in the bells ring to
signal capitulation afternoon eros
ignores the surrender and unleashes her
firepower on the city the question
becomes not whether Circe will fall but
when suddenly the stakes just don't seem
all that high anymore
meanwhile the entire first act of the
Battle of Winterfell is a masterclass in
tension there's a long eerie silence
punctuated by spare bits of dialogue
with just over ten comprehensible lines
spoken within the first 20 minutes of
the episode the charging Dothraki look
like darts or arrows of light advancing
into the blackness when their war cries
suddenly go silent that's when the real
darkness sets in it's not only the
annihilation of the Dothraki who've been
with us from the very beginning of the
show but also the extinguishing of that
initial glimmer of hope more terrifying
is a suppor chanak described it like any
good monster movie we're not allowed to
see the monsters this is the same
technique famously used by Steven
Spielberg and jaws drawing on the
Hitchcockian idea of the unseen enemy
throughout this episode we'll see that
the setting of each act is in service of
its specific genre here we're on open
fields in a pitch-black night where for
a long time it's impossible to see what
we're up against even as the whites
charged the initial stages of
hand-to-hand combat are dominated by a
sense of total confusion especially
after the ice storm hits in terms of
battle clarity well that's one domain
where King's Landing clearly wins its
shot in broad daylight where we can see
every detail of the bloodbath
long night on the other hand was set in
the darkest hours in a controversial
decision heavily criticized by the
show's fans it meant that we have to
rely on silhouettes to discern the
action or at least to get the gist of it
but that's very much the point in this
battle especially during this act and
not only instills in us that fear of the
unknowable it's also an articulation of
how this fight would really feel on the
ground
frenzied chaotic and totally
disorienting
as the living are forced to retreat back
into the castle the chaos quickly
devolves into a horror show that feels
something like a zombie invasion it's
turning to hell for every character we
can now see in horrifying clarity how
the whites move in that contortionist
glitchy way reminiscent of the kinds of
monsters seen in movies like The Grudge
full slasher mode soon gives way to a
quieter type of survival horror as we
move inside the buildings of Winterfell
Arya's cat-and-mouse sequence feels like
a tribute to the iconic kitchen hunt
from Jurassic Park both of these scenes
take place in familiar settings that are
supposed to be safe but are actually
crawling with invaders the familiarity
of Winterfell interiors is an especially
terrifying aspect of the scene until now
the castles inside spaces have offered
refuge from the chaos raging outside now
as showrunner David Benioff said these
hallways and rooms where we spent a lot
of good times and quiet times with
characters we care about have become a
horror set the threat is more intimate
now and the deathly silence makes
moments like this inverted jump-scare
truly jarring our sentimental ties to
Winterfell make this a more ghastly
scenario as viewers we never have that
kind of relationship with for example
King's Landing that cities associated
with the suffering of many characters at
the cruel hands of the Lannisters
so Daenerys is onslaught doesn't seem
quite so at odds with the setting on the
other hand the site of Winterfell
overrun with the dead feels like a
terrifying break with the past battle
drums lead us into the next act and were
plunged into a full-on action movie
we follow John as he charges through the
castle heading right into the thick of
battle here's a posh Nick takes another
page out of Steven Spielberg's book
using the battlefield camera approach
that worked so well in Saving Private
Ryan the camera flows through the castle
staying with John every step of the way
he's running full tilt and so are we
we've been through scene after scene of
complete devastation
what's the posh Nick called the it'z
shots the camera ducks underneath swords
and daggers and dodges spinning bodies
and jumping whites were inserted into
the action and we can feel how
all-encompassing and claustrophobic it
is as the trench is dying down the
moonlight suddenly becomes introduced
again we're starting to come full circle
the end is near and as we haven't seen
Arya for a good chunk of time were
tricked into putting all our hope into
John when his prospects look grim that's
when the dismay really starts to set in
and then we get to the pure drama of act
for the night King is advancing into the
godswood the most sacred place in
Winterfell
the ancient where would where bran
awaits him has stood at the center of
that Grove for 10,000 years and it's
been the site of many fond memories the
night Kings invasion into this
touchstone of Winterfell feels tragic
and nightmarish consistent with these
extraordinary circumstances the sequence
pretty much breaks all the stylistic
rules of the show it's an extreme
slow-motion mostly shot in 96 frames a
second slo-mo is a style that Game of
Thrones reserves for only its most
dramatic and tragic moments
instinctually we know what this means
all bets are off this heightened reality
is reminiscent of Akira Kurosawa
the Japanese filmmaker who pioneered the
use of slow-motion often to heighten the
drama in a climactic scene so posh Nick
is using slow-motion in the same
haunting anguished way as Kurosawa whom
he cited as an inspiration before this
is also by far the most screen time the
night Kings ever gotten more than double
the amount he got in Hart home or beyond
the wall it seems unreal seeing so much
of him and so close-up as a patch Nick
said the whole thing is designed to feel
like a surreal
nightmare Danny's reign of terror two
episodes later would have benefited from
some of these close-ups
after all the dragon Queens total heel
turn
transformed her suddenly into a road
tyrant this moral reversal might have
been more chilling if we'd seen the
reaction or non reaction on her face as
she incinerated the city below her
instead were detached from this new
villain after she embarks on her rampage
she and rogue on just become distant
figures in the sky the nightmare of the
long night is much more immersive
ambient noise is muted the sound of
people's grunts and blows become muffled
and it feels like a trance State the
mood of despair is reinforced by the
night Kings theme a haunting piano led
track
[Music]
and then comes Aria delivering what the
New Yorker called the stab heard around
the world
most of the action up till now has been
hard to follow for an hour plus we've
been in a state of total disorientation
whether it was a result of the shaky
handheld camera and quick editing of the
first act or the hyper surreal nature of
this final act they kept us in the dark
both literally and figuratively for so
long but arias delivering the fatal blow
brings a moment of sudden clarity
slicing through our dreamlike state see
how the storyboards from the sequence
emphasised the clarity of every movement
this was an immediately iconic moment
and a dramatically satisfying conclusion
to a battle that almost ended an
existential ruin if we graph the main
narrative beats over the duration of the
episode the progression of the battle
would look something like this what
makes the long night special well the
structure of the plot matches the shape
of the battle itself as the dead advance
on Winterfell with each retreat of the
living the invading threat penetrates
deeper and deeper into the heart of
Winterfell as each line of defense falls
the intensity heightens this narrative
pattern of concentric rings is fitting
for a show that loves to loop back in
time whether with explicit flashbacks or
more subtle visual parallels is there
going to be a battle in the godswood
throughout the Battle of Winterfell they
kept us invested by keeping the focus on
character with references to memorable
dialogue and formative events from
earlier seasons moments like these
reminded us of our longtime personal
investment in these characters the
episode was firmly rooted in the past
and as a result the emotional stakes
felt quite high
comparing the battles of Winterfell in
King's Landing shows that it takes more
than just massive scale and spectacular
visuals to make a great war sequence the
long night was a brilliantly tortuous
ride in which we experienced the full
spectrum of war
the uncertainty in doubt given way into
terror adrenaline and tragedy I'm not
afraid to call it a masterpiece
[Music]
you
[Music]